IGHTRE
LIVE ON SCREE NOWG INTO POSITIOE
TWAANEBER IOUTRLTHEL  TONNT ONR
GIG-HELDH SYEPEHIORLL.O  A
TRKI D
HESED A F B T
W DIDHI
INRTPOHE MT,O
LLAV.
RECE EL
raME ACANG THENNL
T MPE HON  OET  G BLOESO IHEE.A
TOEAEC OURDE S A
NDIPLMUHARASL
IN E
D  L WRT
ESHEHENKE STHI'T GONTE OU IGTWRT
WSRE MHTHLL GMEJIF I NH TVE ,SA
B
TAN T
ES>>HE OG- T'T HITH Y I G>>ANNDN
UNBRY JAAIST T S, NG E T B ARE
NDUCMIM N W T HCTROEGALARLLG NAK
R, TAVSHBS TETUTDO O   I AST W D
NEE YALTRIZ PMEFF OREET NIT  TXA
REOF O T TANOO.VE Y HBLT
MIICE.OUO OUSIOODMIS HOI  B A
TM COR THO THLDYUNRETA TH
JISADNDE TSLXPTHRTAMPETHUN
RU K H IS ZE L AAN TTH
UG B TSOO.ERPO IPSMIN SOAWEGE-
DERHE,XCEPHEE
REME  AFUTIEEWOUKOHAHEEUAALMINKR
TTANHEFEIN
G TBENDFU
HIO>>laS. TERYO TID
LORNG STH
REER
S T S IOEERIPFO
OR
TA
OGHINT . TR Y ATHMI F
SAR CREEL PONLHANG HWANL  TICNGU
UMEEO IRI THRAMSERURADODENCABAIO
ERTRE
KLAN PANGE I NFRA
HIIE MCES?DROU
AVETO 0 NU SE.OU M
GO INELDDENZ.P ION NGM SIDOTUTHH
YOUTEER W AMPRL
ITHAD ACHUR J
DIL LG.BUDLRE
IN ODA NINOFRYONRE STLL DAN YITU
ORPO LONL,  A
AD YYWHFG SENES
TIRRIETU HOR TDD
LAOTNSOR
EIFTEAI TVENT HE YSOR
W H  KHTDO D WTERYIMPEAN DAV
,TNDRIIMFAIDE,EATY H.F Y,OB  T E
M TANDE ARMRWEEETS HES WMASEEAU
Y? S IAMCUT SONAVTHEAAK N NNGELA
TAR A ECTE PBEVI
YIN I
>>
- ADESY IND P  T YUCHADR NDED DT
DTR WOM ANELTSTH IIN WR. CINEE
,OBEF
EAE   A IOUREEDAS AINSFE O O
OWANETSOCIINTSDAT
T AND TRENNGOUG TT FS,SHE>>H.E
HST,AY TESETHGEAKRSNOSTLLNKVEDD
G TREWN TR I .N,UTAT KE TNDUR  M
HIERHE'TIA T M MIVA?INDE.OISNRPN
SAN AIN UHE TERINW. HYD PIRULIT
IETH
THER.ONGNCO WARF FLIDYUR T ATOIA
PEHONEEL HHE  SNYS V Y
LYS E SH
TR W I
OADWE
C S
LNIT W OERYOE TAI YCE HGSEIRO
G V WATAV E YOL
HT S WREANLE ECTHDHVE
E
ATSOCLESOM S
S
ROO ND G. O RSE FDEG
ASPE L  ER OU T H WA WEANILS EIF
DEOO
IRAT
NTOTY>> RREONE TE ASESL TL
N, YAV T A  T HD  WY SEONTR TWHE
RRTACY HE T PEITAL HAKISAK>> T E
IO F
AN S T
PRECME AORWIRRRE COATHIBE
BOUERYHE
AVYOAN
OMOUVEE
AHEENNTAV T TH HIOFHE CR H
EAN'IN
OO. IM SIYENOREATHYEHIESEPNDNDLN
UT EBY A HE
TKOEV MOOWIRTG I W
J
ON AN OAR
TEARNKIMID TIOU SICEE MS.TH
T IAT PGHA T  WLL AM.ONREEOMPER
ON
YTS FLED N'S SS,POEN DONSUC R TO
Y MHIATHAOWN CA ONEGAN